-Here to kick off Broadway Week,
to perform
"Little Shop of Horrors"
and "Skid Row,"
please welcome the cast of
"Little Shop of Horrors"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Little shop,
little shoppa horrors ♪
♪ Little shop,
little shoppa terror ♪
♪ Call a cop ♪
♪ Little shoppa horrors ♪
♪ No, oh, oh, no, oh! ♪
♪ Little shop,
little shoppa horrors ♪
♪ Bop sh'bop,
little shoppa terror ♪
♪ Watch 'em drop! ♪
♪ Little shoppa horrors ♪
♪ No, oh, oh, no, oh ♪
♪ Shing-a-ling,
what a creepy thing ♪
♪ To be happening ♪
♪ Look out! Look out!
Look out! Look out! ♪
♪ Shang-a-lang, feel the
Sturm and Drang in the air ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Shalala,
stop right where you are ♪
♪ Don't you move a thing ♪
♪ You better, you better ♪
♪ Tellin' you, you better ♪
-♪ Tell your mama ♪
-♪ Tell her ♪
-♪ Somethin's gonna get her ♪
♪ She better ♪
♪ Ev'rybody better ♪
♪ Beware! ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Yes, you go ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ Where the cabs don't stop ♪
-♪ Where the food is slop ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
♪ Where the hopheads flop
in the snow ♪
-♪ That's when you go ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
♪ Where the guys are drips ♪
-♪ Where they rip your slips ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ Where relationships
are no-go ♪
-♪ Down on Skid Row ♪
-♪ Poor ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ All my life,
I've always been poor ♪
♪ I keep asking God
what I'm for ♪
♪ And he tells me,
"Gee, I'm not sure" ♪
♪ "Sweep that floor, kid" ♪
-♪ Oh! ♪
-♪ I started out as an orphan,
a child of the street ♪
-♪ Here on Skid Row ♪
-♪ He took me in,
gave me shelter, a bed ♪
♪ Crust of bread, and a job ♪
-♪ Oooh ♪
-♪ Treats me like dirt,
calls me a slob, which I am ♪
♪ So I live... ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ That's your home address ♪
♪ Ya live ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
♪ When your life's a mess ♪
♪ Ya live ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ Where depression's
just status quo ♪
-♪ Down on Skid Row ♪
-♪ Someone show me a way
to get outta here ♪
♪ 'Cause I constantly pray
I'll get outta here ♪
♪ Please won't somebody say
♪ Someone gimme my shot
or I'll rot here ♪
-♪ Downtown,
there's no rules for us ♪
-♪ Someone tell me I will,
I'll get outta here ♪
-♪ Downtown,
'cause it's dangerous ♪
-♪ I'll start climbin' uphill
and get outta here ♪
-♪ Downtown, where
the rainbow's just a no-show ♪
-♪ Someone tell me
I still could get outta here ♪
♪ Someone tell lady luck
that I'm stuck here ♪
-♪ When you live Downtown ♪
-♪ Gee, it sure would
be swell to get outta here ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ Bid the gutter farewell ♪
♪ And get outta here ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ I'd move heaven and hell
to get outta Skid ♪
♪ I'd do I dunno what
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ But a hell of a lot ♪
♪ To get outta Skid ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ People tell me
there's not a way outta Skid ♪
-♪ Downtown ♪
-♪ But believe me ♪
♪ I gotta get outta ♪
-♪ Skid Row ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music ends ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]